the one thing I think your background
has in common other what many things I'm
sure but you both started or had a good
degree of time as story artists I've
worked since about 96 doing storyboards
over at DreamWorks and over at Sony as
well so yeah okay so talk about what
that process is and how you got to that
position and then why as a story artist
you then were were chosen to direct I'm
just curious about that because it's a
little yeah it's a little bit different
well I think you know the closest sort
of related live-action job this story is
probably the writers room we speak in a
very visual language and a lot of what
we try to do is make the movie before we
make the movie and we experiment because
animation is very expensive so you know
you want to kind of go through that
iterative process and we we work very
closely with the writers and and we
spend a lot of time drawing and
redrawing the movie it's like a comic
strip panel that then gets put the time
and in that world you're kind of mini
directing your sequences when you're
owning them you know up to the point
where you send it to editorial where
it's cut in to time you drawing
character and camera at the same time
and a lot of times we get up in pitch so
we're also performing all the characters
which is sort of how we get a lot of
voices in the movies too because they
get used to hearing us play the
characters and so there's a lot of
invention and a lot of kind of iteration
in that what-if world that we that we
spend time in and I think that's
probably one of the things that one of
the reasons why a lot of story artists
become directors because in in the
directing chair you're dealing with a
lot of you know the what-if and you're
kind of creating something from scratch
and so we spend time doing that we also
get exposed to the studio system the
executives you know how to kind of get
something through so there's the
business side of how you make something
you know which is important to learn so
how do you rise to the top in that I
mean what's the lore I think they they
really liked our storyboards and they
liked the ideas that we had and both
Chris and I were
on the first cloudy until the very end
of story so Wow yeah I was actually a
cloudy one longer than cloudy - I mean -
it was four and a half years in stories
so Wow yeah yeah and you have to be a
bit like a punching bag I mean like a
lot of its not giving in to sort of your
emotions you just kind of have to keep
bouncing back with new ideas
I would probably throw away 90% of the
drawings that we do yeah there's an old
saying kill your babies I think that's
that they used for writers it's the same
thing for story artists mm-hmm so how
many story artists are there on a
typical film like this and and how do
you what's the hierarchy how do you I
mean sure there's what maybe eight to 12
people and then we up until about the
end it was really down to a crew of
maybe four or five yeah and then we have
a head of story who we delegate a lot to
and I had a story basically lives in
editorial with us and now stuff changes
that stuff develops you know it's his or
her job to kind of be point man at
communicating all that stuff back
through the team so I think that the
there's a lot of co-directing going on
in animation right now and that's like
probably more so than in the live-action
history there's two directors how does
that work with you guys and what's the
division of labor and well there's no
real division at the beginning I mean we
share and everything we're at every
meeting and I use each other like sound
boards yeah coming from story I mean we
like that collaboration and that kind of
conversation that you can get with
another human being yeah and then really
the last six months was when we had to
start splitting up and so maybe one day
Chris would go to animation and I would
go to layout or we'd flop you know so
that we could still have our eyes on
everything and then at the end the day
we just kind of talked about what we saw
and kind of you know go through things I
think unlike live-action which tends to
have a momentum when you get on set that
it just gets done and you're out there
shooting for like what like three weeks
or you know a month or two and animation
takes years so it's nice having some
partner that you can get sick with you
know I can see my kids and you know I
mean like it like it's just it allows
you to kind of be a human being for the
duration of the process so you know and
so how did you two come to be paired
together did you work together as before
and then they said hey these guys off on
open season we won Surf's Up together
and then cloudy we were on at Sony for
over 10
yeah I've been in there for about nine
and a half I was round up so now I just
cross ten so does that mean I should say
ten or nine should I round down you know
they had an idea of switching the genre
like going into the monster movie and
and very quickly it was like the four of
us in the room with her our new writer
Erica rivinoja it was like old days we
were just kind of breaking story and
throwing spaghetti on the wall plus
there was a lot of leftovers from the
first film you know we had the gummi
bears the pizza slices I know full of
puns and it was great to actually come
back and work with that stuff again
because we'd spent at least two years
working on various different like
scenting food moments and it was nice to
come back and finish that we we were
working on a script and of course a
studio needs a touch base every so often
so we we had developed a kind of an
outline for a story we had done some
animation tests with with the strawberry
berry and the pickles and so we went
into Amy and Amy Pascal and Michael
Lynton and we pitched them the story and
it was kind of like bla bla bla bla bla
bla
berry because once they saw that little
running strawberry they they got excited
about the hook of the film so that
really gave us some momentum real
science we studied strawberry
microphones one of the funnest
experience was getting James Caan to
sing with the pickles because uh you
know I I didn't know how that would go
you know he's a very very serious man
he's you know very accomplished actor
and he completely went with it and had a
blast the only problem was he sang at an
Irish it took us like two sessions to
get him off of the Irish thing because
it didn't sound like him